Could mold in my water system be causing high micotox results?
The well has been tested for bacteria and E. coli, but having trouble finding a test for mold.
Yeah, there's not a test for mold that I know of in for your well.
To answer the question, could mold in my water system be causing high micotoxeter results?
I don't think so. I don't think so. I've not seen any data on that.
Your well is a steel pipe. It's not an organically.
Remember, mold wants to grow on an organic substance like a wood or a paper or something like that.
It's not going to grow on metal.
So your metal steel pipe that's in the ground bring you water from down to your water source.
That's not going to be a mold source.
So it can be a bacterial source, but it's not going to be a mold source.